Ryan was asking here in the chat what
kind of main profile pic do you guys
recommend
something candid shots always do great
for whatever reason Canon shots work
really really well even though I use
b-roll everyone knows that Canon shots
are 99 of the time not actually candid
um they seem to work better so you know
that's why getting a photographer that
will come and hang out with you while
you do stuff or you get together with
friends or maybe you know I had a guy
that said hey like uh what we did in
Miami we had guys like making cocktails
and they took some photos of people
doing stuff like that or you know we
just have guys come by when a guy would
be shooting it's like cracking jokes
trying to get them to make trying to get
him to laugh and just kind of look
natural so you know showing that you're
in an environment that is fun and you're
having a good time
um in a candid shot always does kind of
weigh what does it does it does way
better than just straight on looking at
the camera shots and stuff like that so
that's my number one number one tip is
just do stuff that looks candid but
um nothing that obscures your face you
want at least like a waist up photo uh
nothing too far away no sunglasses
um you know so so the puppy thing is a
little bit overblown
but you know the candid shot of you
doing something [ __ ] cool is is the
best spice that I would give
yeah when you get a photographer I
normally tell them
um to start clicking through the role
because now back in the day you only had
what was it like 29 30 I think 32 photos
per roll then you had to drop it off at
the at the pharmacy and then wait a few
days and come back and turn in your
ticket and then half the photos for your
thumb over the lens that that doesn't
exist nowadays with these digital
cameras you can click away you can take
hundreds of photos so I tell the
photographer to if I'm getting into a
pose type situation
um
especially like I do a lot of couple
photos too with girls I date because
it's just a fun afternoon hey let's go
to some cool sites and do some couple
photos and I have photos for thumbnails
for for my YouTube or whatnot but I tell
them to start clicking as we're getting
in the pose and then once they say okay
yeah like you're done then to click a
couple more after that like my best
natural Expressions come right when I
break the pose when I try to pose I look
like I have an extra chromosome but the
minute the photographer is like okay
we're good that's a wrap I'm just like
oh okay yeah it's awesome and then they
usually get a really good natural shot
and those are the ones I almost always
end up using I'm gonna I'm gonna tell
you guys a little bit of a story of of
one of the best photographs that I saw
personally in it and it kind of
summarizes what both moth and jiren were
talking about
um this guy was in our community a few
years ago good dude
um looks a little bit like Colin Farrell
kind of down on himself thought he had
big ears like didn't have have like the
best self-image of himself
and there was a shot that he started to
use I think he was standing at I don't
know like a a craps table or a blackjack
table but some kind of uh gaming table
and everybody was dressed to the nines
he was wearing either a tux or a suit
that that was
um that was fitted to you know his frame
so it looked good he had a good physique
and he had a great smile on his face a
drink in one hand he was like throwing
the dice it was kind of an action shot
and he had two girls on one side and a
guy and another girl on the other side
and they were and the guy was looking at
him like like he wanted to be him and
the girls were looking at him and the
table like they wanted to be with him
and they were all attractive right that
is probably one of the best shots that
you're getting out
can you manufacture that sure but like
you know moth and Jerry were saying you
know if you're doing interesting things
in your life and you want to get sort of
better results with using apps like this
so you don't look like uh
let's see here Dave the chainsaw guy
from the Chainsaw Massacre
um you know do cool things with your
life I mean
when when women look at what you're
doing they're basically
assessing the situation like oh I can
see myself inserted in that photograph
like I want to be there with those
people doing those things because you
can do anything you want to a woman
except for bore her right so if you're
doing interesting things in your life
and you have captivating friends and
they look good and they got style and it
looks like you're doing something
interesting she's going to be more
compelled to sort of dive deeper down
that rabbit hole and you know generate
some sort of interest in you
um so yeah you can dramatically improve
the results that you get when you take
those you know simple steps I talk about
more stuff in my book on the uh chapter
on getting those results in the
unplugged Alpha you can get that on
Amazon
um but there's a sequence of photos that
you can look at you know use after that
um I talk about the mystery shot the ah
shot you know the group of friends shot
all that stuff so you guys can go check
out the book I mean I know a lot of you
have read it already but grab it if you
haven't
um yeah so I don't know man like what
else should we uh cover on I got like
another 20 25 minutes before I got a
bounce is there anything else you got
want to talk about today I've got one
more quick aside on that moth skirted
over but I think it's important then to
note that these apps yes they're called
dating apps but they are targeted for
women so you need to understand who your
Target demographic is that kind of sums
up all the all the in-depth details we
gave but you can tell uh by those
filters too like pay attention to them
fill them out like do whatever
um and the funny thing is you know
they're targeted towards women because
they don't have options like for guys
asking girls are you down to come
straight to the house on the first date
to smash on the first date to spit slap
do whatever so the apps are obviously
towards women and you need to keep that
uh in mind in terms of what women are
looking for on the apps because they'll
they'll disqualify things on the apps
like oh he's five eleven well in real
life most girls don't care about that or
oh he he has this hobby well once you
actually meet her she doesn't really
care about that so only put the
information on there that's going to
give you a leg up on the competition but
don't potentially put anything out there
that might be
um a disqualifier for her her she's uh
swiping through her stack yeah and be
careful about your socials like we talk
about this a lot I mean this recently
just came up you know there's a guy in
the community that met a chick at a bar
and apparently you know really into him
this and that but then he got it like he
didn't close the deal and then got her
Instagram or something like that hit her
up a couple days later and she like went
ghost on him so you know it's
if you're an older guy
that is going to be insistent on dating
younger women you know 20s and 30s
especially in the social media age like
this stuff has to be buttoned up like
you've got to have a tight social media
game because a lot of women before they
even swipe on you they'll if you know if
you got your Instagram link they'll just
go check out your Instagram first or you
know something I've been experiencing
with lately is getting not even using
the dating app like I'll swipe on a
check or
um I'll just get her Instagram directly
from the app and then I'll just hit her
up on Instagram but I can do that
because I've curated and Jaren can do
the same we've curated our social
profiles that are like okay cool this
guy is potentially somebody that does
something that's worth this that's got a
soul Circle that's got a group you know
if and that's that's a big component
that a lot of guys are are missing
especially really high level successful
guys that
um have great interesting lives but
they're just dog [ __ ] at documenting it
they don't take photos they don't take
videos they don't do anything like that
to document their lives and that it's
one of the easiest things that you can
do to up your social proof and to let
these women know that you're a guy that
hey come into my world my world's cool
but
again you know the you can see the
pictures those guys were posting their
first photos like that's their highlight
this guy's like doing chainsaw work or
this guy taking a selfie in his car with
sunglasses on or you know this dude
standing by himself like at a wedding
looking awkward like that's these guys
Best Shot you know that's their
highlight so just got to get better
highlights and the chick said it it's
like dude that's your best photo like
that that that is what you're using like
that's your putting your proverbial best
foot forward and I'll Echo that on the
Instagram a lot of guys come in like
okay well I've got the good tender picks
now or I've got the good Bumble picks
whatever Apple they're choosing to use
but when you get to Instagram Instagram
does most of your heavy lifting for you
uh what the dating apps does um if you
remember like the marketing principles
like uh Ada or Ida like attention
interest decision uh action uh desire
action yeah desire action yeah
um it's that it's that first step
tenders just get her attention and then
you have to build the interest your
Instagram does that for you so it's a
powerful social proof tool when she goes
to the Instagram she will dive into your
photos she'll look at the comments
she'll look whatever so if you have
other hot chicks leaving like heart
faces and kissy faces and oh uh in
Spanish like oh okay or stuff like that
girls are gonna know that and uh the
follower count is a big one too I had a
guy when I first started my Instagram
years ago he's like bro like really work
on building your followers like oh how
do I do that it's like go out and meet
people like or put out content that
people want to share I upload guitar
reels every now and then those always
get me a ton more followers and they're
usually hot chicks from Brazil for
whatever reason people in Brazil like
those no no in Mexico or the US does but
uh what it does is it boosts my follower
account and this guy told me years ago
he's like hey once you hit 2 000
followers on Instagram it's like the
game just suddenly changes like that at
the time that's like the magic number
where girls like oh this guy he's
interesting enough to wear 2 000 people
want to subscribe to see what he's up to
and his day-to-day life and I think I'm
like 5300 or something like that now I
my Instagram does a lot of my work for
me girls I'll go on Tinder my Instagram
is right there they'll just come right
through to my Instagram they'll start
liking videos
um they see I put my YouTube stuff on
there this type of content on there and
it does screen some out but the girls
that do end up coming over like hey I
watched a couple of your videos and like
you seem like you get it like you're
you're a safe option in the sense that
you're not gonna be a weirdo like you
talk about this stuff publicly and it at
the time when I started posting type
this type of content I thought oh no
it's going to ruin my dating life it is
done the opposite it's done a lot of my
work for me yeah it'll filter out a lot
of the ones that you really don't want
any any kind of a connection with anyway
at the end of the day I mean you might
you might push off some of the
attractive ones but who cares I mean if
they don't if they don't you know if
they're gonna have a problem with your
opinion or what you're voicing it's like
who cares whatever you know there's
going to be others
but yeah um social media is important I
mean
I've said this so many times and guys
you know like there's this there's this
notion you know for guys like oh that's
too much work
okay then why are you complaining
right I mean men compete women's shoes
it's been that way for a million years
and if guys like Jaron or Chris are out
there with you know captivating lives
doing cool [ __ ] and they're gonna you
know take a look at their social uh
dating and their Instagram and yours is
again we'll go back to you know Dave
from The Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
that's your Instagram feed guess who
they're gonna pick and you can't get mad
at them like why would you get mad at
these chicks for picking the guy that's
doing stuff interesting that you know
does stuff that with with other
interesting people that they want to
insert themselves into just want to hang
out with Dave the chainsaw dude right
she wants to hang out with the guys that
are doing cool stuff with her life and
it's just as simple as that if you don't
want to compete then you can't get mad
at them for not choosing you you know as
simple as that hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out